oh boy the 5090 is in the house big
thanks to Nvidia for sending me a 5090 a
little bit ahead of time so that I could
take a look and poke at it and run
things and try to understand this Mighty
600 watt Beast there's a lot we have to
talk about and not all of it has to do
with gaming a lot of it has to do with
AI but some of it actually has to do
with AI and gaming and frame generation
because a lot of the excitement from CES
has to do with frame generation but a
lot of people are curious is like wait a
minute what about without frame
generation 32 gigs of vram let's unpack
dive in
[Music]
whatever I think this is going to be a
controversial GPU family in general the
90 is probably going to be the least
controversial member of that family but
32 gigs of vram a ridiculous amount of
horsepower we'll go over the physical
specifications of that in just a minute
but the hook the hook is wait a minute
if you compare apples to apples this is
not actually more power efficient than
last generation but it turns out that
that might not actually be important at
all to a lot of people because it's
desktop computer so yeah I
mean another 125 watts over the 4090
maybe maybe is not important not sure
about that the other thing that's going
to be a big controversy is frame
generation is frame generation a real
technology is this a legit way to do
this Nvidia has bet big and they think
yes yes that is the answer but we'll
talk more about that as the review
evolves or unwinds unspools probably is
the better word there let's uh let's
talk physical specifications first for
most of our testing we use this Falcon
Northwest Tiki 9800 x3d based system it
was configured with Expo ddr5 6000
resize bar was on and you know we were
on Windows 11 24 H2 um additionally if
you follow this channel you know that
there's a number of tweaks that we make
to Windows 11 24 H2 for best performance
especially on the AMD platform but just
because you know the operating system
and everything else we also enable
Hardware accelerated GPU scheduling as
this is a recommendation from Nvidia for
D lss3 and
dss4 workloads the fact that a 5090 fits
in here and works fine this is an
insanely screaming fast configuration
from Falcon Northwest you couldn't do it
with a 4090 but now you can with a 5090
thanks to the double flow through design
that works really well for getting rid
of heat it's it's 150 watts more the 590
uses more more power than a 490 and yet
it runs cooler let's talk noise and
thermals for a detailed noise and
thermals analysis you probably should
Che out check out Steve from Gamers
Nexus for me in the Falcon Northwest
Tiki it's subjective it's like can I
tolerate this sitting on the desk and
the answer is yes because at idol you
can't really hear it it's barely Audible
and when I'm playing Indiana Jones in
the great circle even though it's got
bug where I can't put down a screwdriver
which is really frustrating cuz I'm
going to have to roll back over an hour
in order to get to a save from before
that happened um
you can hear the sound of air
movement but it is not annoyingly loud
or whiny or anything else and the fact
that they're able to do that in this
tiny case in 2u is something you
literally couldn't do with a 490 so
that's darn impressive and in case
you're curious about the Falcon
Northwest specific thermals and furmark
results well here they are very
impressive very impressive
build it's the Dual flowthrough design
600 watt 600 watt card and they're able
to that in this this tiny little package
mind-blowing we've also validated the
results from this system on an open test
bench configuration that was also a 9800
X 3D based system and we also did
limited testing on a core Ultra 9 285k
based system with the q1 2025 well
January 2025 updates to the Intel
platform generally the gaming
performance on this system is fantastic
and the core Ultra 2 system was not
quite as good and there's a couple
places where that might make a
difference we'll call that out unless it
gets trimmed because this review is
running kind of long anyway this card
the 90 apart from all of the other 5,000
series cards is the card in this
generation it is truly an upgrade all
the other 5,000 series cards depend on
AI to do their magic and when Jensen
said the 50/70 can deliver performance
like a 4090 wasn't that what he said on
stage cut to the clip with the Blackwell
family RTX
570 49 tiny performance he he means with
upscaling and frame generation features
the AI stuff the AI Special Sauce
impossible without artificial
intelligence impossible without proops
of AI tensor cores impossible without
the G7 memories this card gives you that
but on top of that the most significant
and real I think generational
improvements that are going to come in
the 5000 series are almost all in the
90 period this card gives you
significantly more vram 32 GB which is
important for AI and AI type stuff for
sure for gaming Nvidia says it's not as
important anymore but this card also
piles on the AI features so we still
need it for that they have RTX neural
shaders and RTX neural faces this Nvidia
says reduces the demand on the GPU video
memory for topnotch
textures and I've been playing a lot of
games lot of games last four days still
590 bumps both of the amounts of vram
and or both metrics I mean the amount of
vram in the speed gdr 7 the ri memory
benchmarks are about 80% faster in my
testing which was kind of face melting
like gddr 7 is as fast as hbm from when
hbm first showed up on the scene which
is kind of wild so yeah fun times if you
don't take anything else away from this
review you need to understand the big
picture with gaming and frame generation
and RTX textures and neural textures the
the biggest bet that Nvidia has ever
made with Gamers is in this generation
and probably the biggest potential for
backlash gamer backlash is high the AI
people are don't care their AI people
are going to be super happy uh and we'll
talk about all of this but first let me
show you as I tell you about all the
Wonder and Magic that is the 90 I want
you in your mind to think about it is
native rendering features gen on gen
Improvement like everything the 490 can
do what did the 90 improve and then I
want you to also think about it in terms
of the AI features because a lot of what
you've already seen pre-launch coverage
from Nvidia and CES and a lot of the
Wonder and Magic from that presentation
and all of the data that has been you
know uh trickled out over the last
couple of days is around the new AI
functions and AI functions that improve
gaming not just AI for machine learning
enthusiasts
this generation is all about dss4 and
multiframe generation AI upscaling
neural textures RTX magic and some of
these features are exclusive to this
generation the 5000 series gpus but not
everything some things will actually
work on 4090 4080 somewhere through
there as as Hardware unboxed says this
is really a smoothing technology when
we're talking about frame generation and
for me it's about the overall gameplay
experience is the overall gameplay
experience better do I get better visual
Fidelity smooth gameplay less hitching
yeah Nvidia is keenly aware that they
can't just slap on frame generation and
expect everybody to just use it at the
same time Nvidia has lots and lots and
lots of telemetry about how long you
play what games and at what settings 80%
of Gamers on Nvidia are using dlss today
right now that's dlss 3 3.5
somewhere through there and they know
that because they have that from the
driver Telemetry and that's very
important now everybody knows that frame
generation adds latency but Nvidia is
taking a lot of steps in the design to
minimize that as part of reflex 2 and
for my own testing I can tell you reflex
2 uh it's like just the improvements in
the 5000 series in general and frame gen
is hugely impressive and I'm kind of a
skeptic I'm like actually kind of not
super I haven't been super enthus
thusiastic about dlss technology in the
past if you want the lowest possible
latency sure you're going to have to use
native technology but Nvidia has done
what they've done well and the results
that I've experienced are actually very
good the other thing is image quality
and fine details in dlss 4 show the most
improvement over dss3 and 3.5 with dss3
things like a chain link fence and
cyberpunk and I get that right some of
the time but not all of the time a lot
of the detail and textures with would
get a little mixed up you get shimmering
maybe some weird animation artifacts I
mean okay but that's when you'd really
notice that you were using some kind of
AI technology as opposed to just native
rendering because something weird was
happening and you know across games now
with the lss4 not so much the lss4
impresses me and that is that's saying
something I'm surprised that it is as
good as it is NVIDIA says they've dumped
Millions upon millions of dollars in it
and I kind of believe it after playing
with it if you got a 5090 you would
think that you need to rely on these
kinds of Technologies but you know it's
like you kind of do and its efficacy
will vary from game to game but as a
smoothing technology it has helped as
far as I can tell and helped in a way
that it hasn't on previous generations
and I don't think that I'm describing
really a smoothing technology describing
it as smoothing doesn't really do it
justice when you experience it this is
nvidia's big bet this is the one where
there may be gamer backlash but remember
Gamers have been using this Tech 80% of
the time so let me share with you this
important bit from the reviewer guide
this is verbatim from Nvidia when
GeForce RTX 50 Series graphics cards hit
store shelves GeForce RTX 50 Series
Gamers will be able to multiply
performance with dlss multiframe
generation in 75 games and apps and all
GeForce RT X users will be able to
experience the new Transformer based
dlss Ray reconstruction dlss super
resolution and daa in over 50 games and
apps two for many games that haven't
updated yet to the latest dlss models
and features the Nvidia app will enable
support through a new dlss override
feature alongside the launch
of our RTX or GeForce RTX 50 series gpus
after the installation of a new GeForce
game ready driver and the latest Marvel
Rivals and Dragon Age The Veil guard at
launch Gamers will have access to 75
supported dlss override titles now the
actual launch where you can buy a card
is in another week or so so this is
something I'll be revisiting these
titles that I've been able to test for
this video are the absolute best
possible case put forward by Nvidia for
all these new technologies so I think
because of that you have to take that
with a little bit of grain of salt which
is why I shared that with you as for
other games like cyberpunk 2077 Allen
wake 2 etc etc I have access to the beta
versions of those games and those games
add support for these Technologies
natively so I don't need the the Nvidia
app to override what the game is doing
and set it in the app I can just set it
in the game so it's not like I only test
two games I'm just letting you know that
there's more and that the efficacy and
how good it is in other games is
probably going to be variable multiframe
generation is a 50 Series feature only
so well actually a lot of these features
rely on the AI stuff and Advanced Driver
features of the card and remember when
the driver update a few weeks ago hurt
performance when the app was installed
now we kind of know why on 40 series but
you know considered considered for a
second that you know this could be a
source of big drama depending on how
bigger channels spin the AI features and
upscaling and gen on- gen uplift it's
that whole AI context versus you know
traditional GPU functionality context
there's two different things going on in
this one card cyberpunk 5090 no
upscaling none of that going on I'm
outside not the built-in Benchmark 54
FPS I'm tooling around 2.5 GHz GPU
frequency this isn't bad I mean this is
a significant uplift over the 4090 but
it's not 384 FPS and if we look at our
kilowatt we see that the system is using
about 720 Watts now let me change this
to enabl dlss and frame scale and get to
that glorious 364 FPS but we want to
look at the power utilization this is
just a r tracing Ultra preset but I've
restarted the game 200 220 FPS but we're
using about 100 Watts Less on the
kilowatt the GPU is actually doing less
work but more importantly this is only
120 HZ monitor we're rendering frames
that it's really not going to make sense
to look at all right so with my target
of 120 FPS dialed in in cyberpunk now my
GPU is only using about 450 Watts 370
Watts less here's the thing though I
would like for the GPU to render as many
real frames as possible and then make up
the difference to get me to 120 FPS
using frame generation and there's not
really a way to do that as far as I can
tell at least with cyberpunk in most of
the games that I tested I would I would
much prefer to use frames rendered by
the game more of those and less of the
ones that are created using the real
frames in the
game there's not really a way to do that
this is always going to air on the side
of frame generation which uses less
power overall so when I've got a setup
that exactly matches my super fancy
pants monitor 4K 120 HZ the GPU is going
to use less power and I'm going to get
more
AI generated frames than real frames I
would like it the other way around I
think that's reasonable there should be
a way to do that and there probably will
be if enough people notice that and
complain but just thought I'd share okay
so to really emphasize what's going on
there with cyberpunk with what I was
trying to show you as a gamer got my
fancy pants monitor I want to experience
native performance as close as I can and
rely on AI and frame gen only when I
really need it so if my card can do 100
FPS and I've got 12 FPS monitor I'd like
native rendering you know for 100 HZ I
mean I I can get my fancy 120 HZ display
to be at 120 HZ all the time or I can
you know rely on free sync to just you
know it's about 100 HZ okay that's fine
when I turn this on for frame gen I can
tell that the card is actually using
significantly less power it's actually
running at about 60 HZ and doubling that
to 120 HZ for 4K it uses a lot less
power it's way more power efficient in
that respect but I'm getting way less
aely rendered frames than what I would
get with the frame generation turned off
it's like it's just a little too slow
for my monitor I want it to be a little
faster and I think Gamers might not like
that I think Gamers want to get as many
natively rendered frames as possible and
frame gen can make up the difference but
we can see that that's not happening
currently because of the power usage of
the cart now I can fiddle with it maybe
and do the settings and get it to behave
more like I want but it doesn't really
natively think that way it's like oh 60
hertz ly you know multiframe gen or you
could do multi frame gen again another
level and go from 60 to 240 I mean
natively it's true that the higher your
native frame rate the better off you're
going to be with multiframe generation
Technologies cuz I guarantee you the
difference between 120 and 240 HZ those
generated frames you you don't have a
lot of wall clock time there to see that
frame and if half of the frames are real
and half of them are AI generated you
don't really know but from my own
personal experience half of them or you
know a third of them or a quarter of
them being real and the other ones being
AI generated it was really hard to tell
in a lot of cases the AI generated
frames looked better than the real
frames from the game because you know
the game you think about the 590 and its
position and Behemoth like qualities it
can it can punch through the traditional
stuff but also do the AI stuff so it's
sort of The Best of Both Worlds here uh
but it's not just frame generation
Nvidia also has the neural compression
and textures and neural rendering for
people to make everything a little bit
more lifik it can recreate a lot of
complexity and complexity that shows up
in detailed textures without actually
having the uh large detailed textures
which take up a lot of vram and so
that's what Nvidia means when they say
ah I don't really need as much vram
anymore that's also why the 5090 is kind
of the best card in this generation
again it's got a ridiculous amount of
vram so if you do want to put yourself
in a situation where you're loading
ungodly textures and you don't want to
use the RTX compression features you
have the vram to do it or if AI
functions or anything else it's just
other cards farther down the stack you
might not have the option and so like
the 5070 5070 for example is way
more going to lean on the AI features
and everything else at least I think it
does so if you game with a 5070 you'll
have a lot of these AI features that I'm
describing and I don't think you're
going to have a bad gaming experience
with those but my suspicion is that the
non- aai features just the the raster
stuff the stuff in the other column
you're not going to see as much uplift
gen on gen from from 4,000 series or or
other competing products the other thing
I worry about here is when you use
Advanced software features at the same
time as you want to play a game so like
the Nvidia broadcast software which
we'll talk about in just just a second
which is actually surprise
mind-blowingly cool you're going to have
to make sure that you got enough
Headroom on your card to juggle the
gaming workload as well as the AI stuff
and it seems seems like the frame
Generation stuff really frees up a lot
of Headroom on your card to be able to
do all this other stuff there's even a
warning in the Nvidia broadcast setup
guide that you need at least a 5080 for
the highest end features for streamers
now there's a video on Nvidia broadcast
that you should definitely watch because
it's mind-blowing and that was a more
advanced version of the new Nvidia
broadcast software than I had access to
for this review but Enid's big bet here
is that Gamers will be happy with a
lower-end GPU that has less vram and
less transistors allocated toward the
native rendering stuff that historically
has gone into gpus and more of the
transistors and features and technology
is going to be allocated for these AI
features under the AI umbrella not for
like large language models and image
generation you can use it for that but
these gaming features and as they're
demonstrating here they're getting a
much bigger gaming bang for the the buck
or bang you know in terms of how many
FPS did you get per transistor and you
know unit resource that went into the
GPU versus how much you get from native
rendering and scaling native rendering
the 590 80% faster memory 30% more card
but at 30% more power 30% faster overall
in those raster tasks while being 2 and
1/2 to three and 1/ half times faster
for literally everything else AI related
the coup to Performance is breathtaking
we'll talk about that too don't worry I
don't necessarily see the frame
generation and the AI stuff as a bad
thing the fly and the ointment is always
going to be the latency part of that but
you know maybe the visual Fidelity a
little bit the little visual artifacting
thing shimmering other types of the
little weird side effects that can come
from essentially you know a smoothing or
interpolation technology if you will
interpolation Technologies are not in
and of themselves bad uh fora
Transformations facilitate uh a lot of
interpolation for computation and other
computing contexts so finding a way to
do fast High Fidelity approximation in a
gaming context 80% of people so far
don't have a problem with this or at
least they don't seem to based on usage
we'll talk a little bit more about that
in the conclusion though let's take a
look at the actual benchmarks the actual
gaming stuff because I've rambled about
this long enough with this you know
native performance uplift versus AI
performance uplift that's what I want
you to keep in the back of your mind
it's like is this is this because
they've improved the gaming the the the
pure old School gaming part of it or is
this because of the jiz new AI features
because there's two columns there first
up cyber Punk
2077 and an Apples to Apples comparison
490 versus 590 it's a 34 FPS versus 59
FPS battle I
mean it's really not super impressive
but you turn on the AI features and oh
boy uh at this one particular Freeze
Frame during the canned Benchmark 61 FPS
versus
472 yes but let's look at the detail
look look at the water on the sidewalk
and look at the fine detail in the soda
machine dss4 on it looks like it picks
up some of the fine detail and the
filtering neural algori than whatever
actually makes it a little bit more well
defined but you lose some detail in the
water now dss4 off for the water that's
up here I think looks a little better
but the water down here doesn't look
quite as good whereas with dlss for on
the water down here looks a little
better but the details here are a little
bit more muted it's interesting it's
very very interesting you notice little
things like that now in terms of real
motion gameplay DLS S4 on pretty
satisfying especially on that oily D
monitor OLED one of the things I always
love to look for when we're talking
about AI frame gen is Lighting in
Shadows and cyberpunk provides tons of
opportunities for that there's still
jittery shadow Shadows a little bit but
this is really really subtle and you
have to be looking for this and this is
a n and day improvement over a dss3 so
this is a huge engineering win for
NVIDIA that this works as well as it
does the main caveat here is that okay
the canned Benchmark is not really
representative of overall cyberpunk
performance and again if I've got a 120
or 240 HZ display I would like for as
many of these frames as possible to be
real and it's not a fine grain enough
control to set you know frame gen 2X or
FR frame gen 3x if I set frame gen 3x
then I'm topping out the capabilities of
my monitor but the GPU could be
generating more normal frames as opposed
to AI generated frames which may lead to
a better gaming experience I'm just not
sure about that Star Wars Outlaws was
another title that Nvidia was Keen to
show and I can see why it looks really
really good and it runs buttery smooth
it runs smoother than I have ever
experienced I have not logged a lot of
time in this game unlike cyberpunk but
it is really really good performance
with FSR 4 FSR 4
is shockingly good in this title you can
kind of look at our outdoor scene here
with running and see some mild
Reflections on the the texture on the
ground and some lighting effects and I
you know this seems to look better with
the the AI effects than without even
though you know it's kind of it's sort
of wild so let's take a closer look at a
at a multi-game Roundup 4K highest
preset Ray tracing on dlss off and frame
gen off now the highest preset is not
like psycho in cyber Punk just to be
clear but Dragon Age
vard cyberpunk 277 Indiana Jones and the
great circle Star Wars Outlaws this this
doesn't look amazing it's like 4K
highest preset I I can only get 18 FPS
in Allen wake 2 I can only get 27 FPS in
Star Wars
Outlaws I mean this is a pretty
significant generational uplift 71 to
106 FPS in Hogwarts that's reasonable 88
to 125 FPS in Marvel Rivals okay Dragon
Age Veil guard uh 50 to 73 FPS okay I
mean yeah that's that's that's that's
pretty good almost 60 FPS in cyberpunk
2077 Phantom Liberty that's that's
almost entirely playable so with uh
average FPS highest preset rate tracing
on dls's performance and frame gen off
okay cyber Punk 27 27 Phantom Liberty
we're we're starting to see something
here remember this is a beta branch of
of cyberpunk phantom Liberty Marvel
Rivals of 141 to 175 125 to 145 and this
is remember you get the 2x you get some
generational uplift so this is a new
driver and new software and everything
else so this this makes it look like the
difference between the 4090 and the 5090
is not quite as much as it is because
the 490 is taking advantage of some of
the new software here and so a couple of
weeks ago with an older driver version
maybe some of these numbers were not
quite as in line but then there comes
frame
generation yeah this is where things get
a little insane because remember the
5,000 series can deal with a 3X 4X Etc
so 248 versus 451 FPS and Hogwarts 218
versus 446 and cyber Funk 2077 Phantom
Liberty 160 versus 446 yeah it's just
and everything that I tried I've also
logged a lot of hours in Indiana Jones
in the great circle and that has some
breathtaking visuals it's kind of a lot
of fun that is a more fun game to play
than Crystal Skull was to
watch this is a very very enjoyable
experience Star Wars Outlaws 107 versus
FPS this is uh this is sort of sort of
nuts geekbench 6 should get us a little
bit more grounded in reality that's
going to be less on the AI column and
more in the traditional uplift column
and it's about 15% faster over the
4090 nvidia's dlss test in 3D Mark well
it's 181% faster because dlss on but 30%
faster with dlss off and it's really
interesting how much 30% comes up in
this review 30% faster 30% more power
70% more memory bandwidth 30% more
transistors I mean 30% shows up a lot in
this review Port Royal 42.1% 30% and
then some that's 30% plus 12% I'll take
it proon is a useful AI benchmark and
for the canned proon benchmarks yes
we're talking 18% 32% 28% 34% it's out
around 30% tokens per second 30% 45% 50%
depending on if your model can take
advantage of the new you know int 8
stuff you can get a two and a half times
speed up which is also sort of crazy now
Puget bench 88.1% you get an 88.1%
generational uplift in Puget premere I
don't think premier Photoshop have
really been updated to deal with the the
new hardware maybe we have to wait on a
uh you know like a Creator driver but I
wouldn't hold my breath on this this
part of it getting dramatically better
we yes we did add billions more
transistors from the 490 to the 590 but
almost all of those have been on the AI
side of the equation now for these
canned AI benchmarks I had my own AI
stuff that I wanted to run I'm not able
to run Linux yet because there's not
native Linux drivers but I can run olama
and deal with Cuda on Windows because we
got a lot more Cuda cores in the 590
than we had on the 490 quick note on the
1% lows and the 0.1% lows it's very hard
to accurately get the 1% lows in the
0.1% lows because you pretty much have
to use nvidia's tools to collect that
right now other tools like present Monon
are not really going to work correctly
out of the box and it's sort of more
complicated than I expected so I have
omitted some of that data for this video
for the no frame gen no upscaling no
anything else comparing the 490 1% and.
1% lows to the 59.1% at 1% lows the 590
was at least no worse than the 490 if
anything it was better but again not
really the point of this particular
review and after we've got better tools
for looking at the 0.1% and 1% lows
maybe that's something I can
revisit you have to check out nvidia's
broadcast video the video about where
where broadcast is coming because the
version I have access to is not all
there yet it's an AI virtual assistant
that is absolutely unhinged what I got
access to was virtual key light and
Studio voice those are interesting and
uh they're more likely to be used in
just about any scenario they were
actually very impressive especially
combined with like using a dlsr as a
webcam so that it gets enough detail for
low light on your face you don't have to
have a blinding light in your face it it
can just make it look like you're
lighted which is amazing studio voice
was able to filter out this dual 192
core epic server from the
background that's neat and key light
okay key light's cool but you can take a
lot of GPU horsepower so like I was
saying earlier it might compete a little
bit with your game but it's a really
neat effect and I think that a lot of
streamers are probably going to use this
I don't personally like having a bright
light in my face when I'm streaming a
game trying to unwind just hanging out
doing fun stuff and so this was a really
neat feature for me the AI stream
assistant thing in nvidia's own video
about what's coming with broadcast they
say in February was much more
mindblowing and that software while it
wasn't ready yet for this video should
be out soon I'm sure it's the Nvidia
Maxine team the Maxine sdks and
everything else were absolutely unhinged
and so this feels like that level of
unhinged in the best possible way uh I'm
sure they're using that for the heavy
lifting on this feature in could
probably sell a subscription to a stream
assistant that is as intelligent as what
they've demoed here it's wild and you
know if you're paying for a $2,000 card
like this you'd better be using the AI
capabilities right I mean far and away
for me that is the biggest justification
for having a graphics card that costs
more than uh most people spend on their
entire
computer gosh it really does feel like
living in the future though so there you
go Nvidia is changing the game literally
and and figuratively if you want 200 FPS
at 4K you're going to have to lean into
frame generation not just upscaling not
just anything else it's a blessing it's
a curse it's it is it a mere smoothing
technology or is it more like using a 4A
transform as an
approximation which you know is entirely
reasonable and widely accepted approach
for things that that applies to I have a
hunch that for high-end cards like this
it's fine it's there's no denying the
engineering prow W to dissipate 600
watts of heat in a 2u configuration with
just two fans I mean that's that's nuts
I it's over a larger area of silicon
that helps versus you know a tiny little
piece of silicon but the two slot dual
flowthrough design really is incredible
this card is casually dumping 600 watts
of heat into your case or in my case
into the room and that is sort of
something the source of the heat is uh
you know that half acre of silicon
underneath the middle part of the heat
SN on that
card that means the source of the heat
is a little bit more diffus larger area
and so it's easier to cool sort of but
it was still an engineering
accomplishment this is kind of like the
the thread Ripper of gpus that we've got
going on here because there's so much
silic in real estate but with frame gen
and the gaming stuff that goes with
frame genen and neural rendering and all
that sort of stuff and you target your
monitor refresh rate you could game at
120 FPS Plus in 300 to 400 watts too
you're not necessarily sucking back 750
watts for your total system power what
I've learned here makes me worry about
the other cards in this generation
though because the 5000 series launch I
mean it's a foregone conclusion if you
look at the the information they've
released on the 5070 it's obviously not
actually as fast as the 490 not really
perhaps perhaps that's a lie but it's a
lie in the direction of the truth I mean
with the 5070 with these new AI features
okay maybe I would believe that it can
look as fast as a 4090 maybe that makes
sense but not natively and that means
most of the the resource Budget on less
expensive cards like the 5070 are going
to go into the AI features and not
traditional raster performance
traditional gaming performance in other
words everything's going to go in that
AI column as opposed to the you know
what you expect for gaming performance
column or gaming features and that's the
thing that Gamers might react badly to
or maybe 80% of them won't care and
they'll welcome these new features and
the 20% are the loudest 20% but these
features are what you're going to need
to lean into to get Stellar gaming
performance numbers as for the 590 it's
the real deal and at least as far as I
can tell even even taking into account
the fake frame stuff or AI stuff you
know it doesn't feel terrible when you
actually use it and side by side with my
setup here The Best of Both Worlds you
know 120 FPS natively versus 240 with
frame gen or like 100ish FPS freesync
g-sync with yeah it was it was I
actually think I preferred the frame gen
setup functionality me personally for
those games and when you get down to it
for those pure raster tests well it's
also not really more power efficient
either than last generation a little
worse perhaps uh more caor clocked a
little slower that's actually more
efficient per unit Cuda barely uh but it
is a two- slot card with a 30% higher
heat load than the much larger 4090
so yeah I mean those two things
I think are going to be the controversy
of this generation the power Stuff Plus
frame generation I think are the big
controversies of this generation of
cards from Nvidia at lower clock speeds
using AI functions it can be more
efficient like to get to 120 FPS if
you're using frame gent it's going to
use less power real world than a 4090
but like for
like H not so much the power efficiency
story is uh some misleading uh stated
another way 240 FPS in this game at a
mere 600 watts versus 43 FPS at 450
Watts on the
490 if we're talking about cyberpunk and
that's not really 100% fair comparison
most of those frames were approximated
you know so it's really like 43 FPS
versus 60 before you get into the frame
gen stuff but if you turn on the frame
gen stuff it actually will use less
power and get you to a it's Madness it's
Madness to buy this car just for gaming
but for gaming game development and
light AI work well there's nothing else
like it and there's nothing else like it
that you can buy and for some people the
32 GB of RAM feature on this card is
going to be worth the price of admission
at $2,000 heck that's going to be a
bargain they'd probably still be
interested at 2500 3,000 that's just the
level of uh crypto oh I'm sorry AI fomo
that we're at right now is people are
willing to buy at those kind of prices
if you have a 4090 should you upgrade
well you could probably sell your 490
for $1,000 and then buy a$ 590 for
$2,000 maybe 2500 you at $1,000 $1,500
that's maybe worth it for gaming and Ai
and everything else but gaming by
itself I can hardly believe that a 490
came out in 2022 that seems like forever
ago if you're just after gaming even 4K
gaming even 4K gaming with r
tracing I think there's going to be
bigger bang for the buck
Alternatives available soon
Nvidia I know 5070 maybe take Nvidia at
their word maybe other things I don't
know 4090 on the used Market you know
you can buy from the dude that's
upgrading to the 5090 I don't know for
me personally yeah I'm probably going to
buy two more good Lord what a card
Nvidia is going to sell every single one
of these cards and it really it doesn't
matter what Gamers think if you're on
team frame gen or you're on Team fake
frames it does not matter these cards
are going to be unobtanium for months
probably because of the features if
nothing else I you know I'm not really
sure what gamers are going to do I'm not
sure I'm not sure how they're going to
take it but this is a card that can do
so much more than gaming it seems like
that uh it's the best of all worlds in
in that scenario so Nvidia really has
done something special here that may
kick off a whole new series of things or
maybe people will be angsty I don't know
I will this level
one I'm sure that we have more videos
coming on this because there's a lot to
cover here especially when broadcast
drops because the broadcast stream
helper thing was just nuts this is level
one I'm signing out you can find me in
the level one forms let me know what
I've missed if you have any questions or
what you'd like to see for a fast
follow-up video I didn't get Linux
drivers for this in time so the Linux
video for this over on the Linux channel
it's going to be a little while sorry
Andor congratulations all right I'm
signing out I'll see you there
[Music]